Hey guys, it's Jan here.
Ryan Reynolds has said that his Deadpool movie
has 'more Easter eggs than the Easter bunny',
so I've put together every easter egg and
reference I could find in this video.
I'm sure you'll have spotted other cool ones
too, so do share those in the comments below.
And just before I kick off, I've got an awesome
giveaway, so if you'd like a chance to win
some cool Deadpool merch, make sure you subscribe
and comment about your favourite easter egg
on this video.
For more details and ways to enter the comp,
check out the Gleam link in the video description
below!
Now, a quick reminder: there will be spoilers
ahead, so if you're not ready for that, check
out my non-spoiler review of the movie here!
First up, the opening credits are littered
with some great meta movie jokes such as starring
"God's Perfect Idiot", "A British Villain"
"The Hot Chick", "A CGI Character" "A gratuitous
cameo" etc.
And floating among the credits is a coffee
cup labelled Rob L. in honour of Deadpool
comic book co-creator Rob Liefeld.
There's also a nod to Ryan Reynold's turn
as Hal Jordan in the 2011 Green Lantern movie
with a Green Lantern trading card popping
out of a wallet.
And a copy of People Magazine floats by with
Ryan Reynolds on the cover as 2010 Sexiest
Man of the Year and later in the movie, Deadpool
stuffs a stack of Hugh Jackman 2008 Sexiest
Man of the Year magazines into his gun bag.
And, as you'd expect, there's a ton of comic-book
references in the movie too.
The humorous scene with pizza delivery guy
Jeremy and apartment owner Mr Merchant is
a subplot that closely resembles a storyline
from the comics where Deadpool was contracted
to kill a pizza delivery guy who'd spread
a nasty rumour about a girl in high school.
In the comics the pizza guy is called Gavin
whereas in the movie Gavin is actually the
first name of the guy who owns the apartment.
Given this sequence involves two guys, a pizza,
and later a girl, it's also a nod to Ryan
Reynold's breakout role as Michael "Berg"
Bergen in the TV comedy series Two Guys, a
Girl and a Pizza Place.
And Deadpool's line 'What situation isn't
improved by pizza?' is another nod to the
situation comedy, or sitcom, that Reynolds
made his name in.
And did you notice that the pizza box is from
Feige's pizzeria?
Which is a nice allusion to Marvel Studios'
president Kevin Feige and former X-Men producer.
Later when Wade meets the girl the pizza guy
was stalking, he says he should have brought
his rollerblades, which is a callback to the
comics where Deadpool goes rollerblading.
Wade's mercenary bar hangout is called "Sister
Margaret's School for Wayward Children", which
is the same as Deadpool's mercenary hangout
in the comics, which is also known as the
Hell House.
Rob Liefeld, Deadpool's co-creator, has a
small cameo as one of the patrons at Weasel's
bar and when Wade walks in for the first time,
you can hear the words say "Fuck Liefeld!",
which is likely an allusion to his controversial
status with some comic book fans.
By the way, Deadpool's costume has the trademark
Liefeld pouches.
And Boothe, one of the mercenaries at the
bar, could be a nod to Assassin-8, aka Andre
Booth, the cyborg killer from the comics.
And the character Buck feels like it's based
on the character Steele Fitzpatrick, aka CF,
who was also a portly mercenary and friend
of Deadpool's at the Hellhouse.
In the movie, Wade Wilson chooses the name
Deadpool from the betting pool that Weasel
runs on which mercenary will die next, a parallel
to the comic book origin story where Wade
Wilson chooses his name from a betting pool
run on which inmate would die next at the
Weapon X government experimentation facility.
One of the other superhero names suggested
by Weasel is Scaredevil, a jibe at Daredevil
who Deadpool has teamed up with in the comics.
And the action scene where Deadpool is fighting
goons in a corridor is reminiscent of a similar
scene in Marvel's Daredevil on Netflix, which
itself was a nod to a fight scene in the movie
Oldboy.
And by the way, Philip Silvera was the stunt
coordinator for both Deadpool and Netflix's
Daredevil.
Wade also joked he should be Captain Deadpool,
which is both a nod to Ryan Reynold's role
as Captain Excellent in the movie Paper Man
and probably also a crack at Captain America.
There's also a bit of parody of Captain America's
shield when Deadpool throws a car wheel rim
at Ajax when they're on the highway.
Talking about names, Deadpool jokes that Ajax's
name sounds 'surprisingly made-up' and that
he probably took it from a dish soap.
He also wonders what Ajax's real name might
be and offers Bruce and Scott as possibilities,
which could be nods to the Hulk's name Bruce
Banner, and Cyclops's name Scott Summers or
Ant-Man's name Scott Lang.
Ajax's obsession with not using his real name,
Francis, is taken from the Deadpool and Death
1998 annual in which Deadpool discovers that
Ajax hates being called by his real name.
And in a post-Breaking Bad world, Ajax's often-repeated
line 'What's my name?'
also has a ring of Walter White's words 'Say
My Name' about it.
The name tag Wade steals from Ajax has the
surname 'Freeman' on it, which is likely a
nod to Marvel comic book inker Jeremy Freeman
who inked an issue of Cable and Deadpool where
Ajax returns from the dead on Wade's TV screen.
Oh, and by the way, in the comics, as in the
film, Ajax explains how his nerve endings
have been scorched so he no longer feels pain.
And because Fox have the movie rights to Marvel's
mutant superheroes X-Men and Marvel can't
use the word mutant in their movies, Ajax's
description of his henchwoman Angel Dust as
'inhumanly strong' feels like a cheeky nod
to Marvel's Inhumans, who are part of the
MCU in Agents of SHIELD and their own upcoming
movie.
When Wade gets a Voltron Defender of the Universe
ring with his arcade tickets, it's an easter
egg to the time in the comics when Deadpool
converted himself into Voltron combining his
supporting Brute Force characters into one
super robot.
And there's another nod to this at the end
of the movie when Deadpool says to Colossus
and Negasonic Teenage Warhead, "for a minute
there it felt like we were 3 mini lion-robots
coming together to form one super-robot".
The movie has some nice hints to Vanessa's
Copycat alter ego in the comics, for example,
the white streaks in her dark hair hint at
Copycat's white hair.
And because Copycat has blue skin in the comics
we sometimes see Vanessa with blue objects
such as her blue bedsheets and her transparent
umbrella which has a blue rim and handle.
When Vanessa says to Wade "[Red's] your colour,
it brings out the bloodshot in your eyes",
it's a nod to Copycat's sometimes red eyes
in the comics.
There's a funny Star Wars joke between Wade
and Vanessa when she tells him to 'ride a
bitch's back like Yoda does Luke's' and notes
she's referencing The Empire Strikes Back,
not the first Star Wars movie.
And when Wade replies to her "it's like I
made you in a computer", it's a cool easter
egg to X-Men 2 when Mystique is searching
through Stryker's computer and Copycat's name
appears.
And in the trailer Vanessa's line "I've played
a lot of roles in my life.
Damsel in distress ain't one of them" is a
reference to both her shapeshifting powers
as Copycat in the comics and also to Morena
Baccarin's multiple TV and film roles such
as Gotham, Firefly, Serenity, V, and many
more.
And at the strip club where Vanessa works,
Stan Lee cameos as an MC introducing the strippers
on stage with the line "give it up for chastity".
And we also hear Lee's voice in the background
at the club saying, "You can't buy love, but
you can rent it for 3 minutes!"
When Wade finds out about his cancer at the
oncologist, there's a nod to Deadpool's hatred
of clowns in the comics when he quips to the
doctor, "You're clowning, not clowning, I
sense clowns."
The Bea Arthur T-shirt Wade wears at numerous
points in the film is a call-back to the comics
where Deadpool is a fan of Golden Girls actress
Bea Arthur calling her the sexiest woman alive.
Back at Weasel's bar, Wade's joke that the
Recruiter's proposal sounds like a dodgy infomercial
is a call-back to the comics where Deadpool
mocks supervillain Taskmaster.
Oh, and when he calls the Recruiter Agent
Smith, it's a nice nod to the Matrix antagonist
of the same name.
And when Wade tells the Recruiter that 'I
tried the hero ... and it left a mark', it's
a dig at his role in the critically panned
Green Lantern movie.
And earlier in the movie at the skateboard
park when Wade looks at his green-rimmed sunglasses
in disgust and throws them away, it feels
like a jab at the Green Lantern's mask.
Later, at Ajax's Workshop, Ryan Reynolds pokes
yet more fun at the Green Lantern movie with
Wade's line "Please don't make my suit green
or animated!".
Also at the Workshop, we get a glimpse of
the mutant Marrow, who has bones which grow
out of her body.
When Wade's in the glass oxygen-deprivation
case, he steals a match from Angel Dust and
lights it as a way to escape.
It feels like a nod to Ryan Reynolds' movie
Buried where he's trapped in a coffin with
nothing but a lighter and a cellphone to help
him get out.
And when Wade emerges from the rubble of the
workshop, it feels reminiscent of the way
Deadpool's hand emerges from the rubble in
the post-credits of X-Men Origins: Wolverine.
Speaking of that movie, there's a side swipe
at that version of Deadpool when in this movie
the Merc with a Mouth says 'shit's just gone
sideways in the most colossal way' and the
camera immediately cuts to an action figure
of the Origins Wolverine Deadpool with its
mouth sewn shut, and the joke continues as
we hear Wade say 'this is my most prized possession',
but as the camera pans up we realise he's
actually talking about Wham!'s Make It Big
album.
And there's another reference later to that
Deadpool when Ajax tells Wade to shut up or
he'll sew his pretty mouth shut.
And also when Wade is in the oxygen-deprivation
tank and refuses to say Ajax's name, we hear
Deadpool's voiceover say: 'sorry, Francis,
my lips are sealed.'
By the way, when Wade jokes that he looks
like he was bitten by a radioactive Shar-Pei,
it's an easter egg to a very similar moment
in Cable & Deadpool #2 which was published
in 2004 and coincidentally seemed to predict
Ryan Reynolds would play Deadpool.
There's several Spider-Man references in the
film too including the line "Go get her tiger"
which Weasel says to Wade and which Deadpool
also later says to Negasonic Teenage Warhead.
The line's an echo of Mary Jane's words to
Peter Parker "Go get 'em, tiger" at the end
of the Spider-Man 2 movie.
And when the action freezes Deadpool mid-air,
we find him in a typical upside down Spider-Man
pose.
Spider-Monkey from the alternate Marvel Apes
universe also gets a mention when Deadpool
is fighting 2 female opponents.
And in Wade's final voiceover his mention
of "your friendly neighbourhood pool guy"
is an obvious play on Spider-man's popular
phrase "your friendly neighbourhood Spider-man".
There's also a street sign for Parker Boulevard.
And a host of other streets signs are nods
to the comic books or the movie itself including
Fabian Road and Nicieza Street, which are
named after Deadpool co-creator Fabian Nicieza,
Miller Street named for director Tim Miller
or actor TJ Miller who plays Weasel, Silver
Avenue and Shaham Circle which are nods to
Deadpool VFX coordinators Scott Aaron Silver
and Tamar Shaham.
There are also loads of jokes and references
to Fox's popular mutant movie franchise, X-Men,
including a glimpse of the X-Jet.
When Colossus says they're off to see Professor
X, Deadpool asks "McAvoy or Stewart?
These timelines are so confusing".
Deadpool's joke about only ever seeing two
X-Men at the mansion and not being able to
afford more X-Men characters is a reference
to this R-rated movie's tight budget compared
to the budget of many PG13 superhero movies.
And Negasonic Teenage Warhead pokes fun at
the franchise with jokes about matching unitards
and a house that blows up every few years.
And Deadpool's tirade about the 'Neverland
mansion', in other words Xavier's home for
gifted youngsters, and Charles Xavier being
a "creepy Heaven's Gate-looking motherfucker"
is a nod to some of Professor X's less savoury
moments in the comics, for example, when he
admitted he was in love with the 15-year old
Jean Grey.
When Colossus tells Negasonic Teenage Warhead
that breakfast is the most important meal
of the day and offers her a protein bar, it's
a call-back to a 'Candy Variant' cover of
Deadpool which features a fake advertisement
for a protein bar.
Marvel issued the cover as a dig at their
rivals DC who had been running half-page Twix
ads in their comics.
By the way, that cover also shows Deadpool
and Rhino fighting and there was a Rhino easter
egg in Weasel's bar with a Rhino head trophy
on one of the walls.
When comic book writer Grant Morrison created
Negasonic Teenage Warhead, he named her after
a song by American rock band Monster Magnet.
In the movie, Deadpool thinks it's the 'coolest
name ever', which is exactly what the screenwriters
thought too which is why they included her
in their script!
In the comics, Warhead is a member of the
Hellfire Club and a student of telepath Emma
Frost, whereas in the movie she's an X-Men
trainee, and later at the junkyard we see
her in the X-Men uniform.
And let's not forget the reference Deadpool
makes to X-Man Hank McCoy when he asks Colossus
to tell Beast to stop shitting on his lawn.
I just mentioned the junkyard, well, when
Deadpool arrives there, his line "time to
make the chimi-fucking-changas" is a cool
nod to the comics where he has a penchant
for repeating the word "chimichanga" over
and over because he likes the way it sounds.
As Deadpool, Warhead and Colossus stride in
to confront Ajax and his gang, the hip hop
song "X Gon' Give It to Ya" by DMX plays,
which is a nice nod to the Weapon X program
which created Deadpool.
When Deadpool removes his underwear to use
as a white flag in the junkyard scene it's
a nod to a similar moment in Deadpool #31.
There's a great moment when Deadpool's fighting
one of Ajax's men and suddenly they stop and
the other guy is revealed as Bob who Deadpool
knows.
This funny scene could be a nod to Bob, a
Hydra agent who has numerous storylines with
Deadpool in the comics.
Or given that Deadpool mentions Jacksonville
and that the food Bob's wife makes is bad
for the waistline, the character could be
a reference to "Billy Bob" Reilly, who grew
up in Jacksonville and whose alias is Phat,
spelt P-H-A-T.
In fact, the character Phat actually appeared
in X-Men: The Last Stand.
And when Ajax says to Deadpool "I hear you
grow back body parts […] when I'm finished,
body parts are gonna have to grow back you",
well, it resembles the time in Cable & Deadpool
"If Looks Could Kill" when Deadpool regenerates
after being turned into nothing but a puddle.
And when Ajax sticks a knife in Deadpool's
head and he starts to hear Chicago's "You're
The Inspiration", it's a call-back to Cable
and Deadpool #49 when Ka-Zar sticks a knife
through Deadpool's head while a tune plays
in the background.
The final showdown on what looks like a rusty
old helicarrier and the post-credits joke
about Samuel L. Jackson showing up is a poke
at Marvel's Cinematic Universe.
Ok, let's talk about the fourth wall.
In the comics, Deadpool famously breaks the
fourth wall and the movie certainly doesn't
disappoint.
There's a moment where Colossus tells Deadpool
he can hear him talking and Deadpool replies,
"I wasn't talking to you, I was talking to
them", which is a nice call-back to a similar
moment in the comics between Deadpool, Benjamin
Franklin and SHIELD agent Emily Preston.
There are loads more examples such as when
Deadpool flicks chewing gum on the camera
lens while in the taxi.
Also, when he talks to the audience saying,
"Oh hello, I know right, whose balls did I
have to fondle to get my own movie?!
Rhymes with Poolverine, and let me tell you,
he's got a nice pair of smooth criminals down
under", he adds in his best Aussie accent.
Of course, there's more ribbing of Hugh Jackman
later when Wade reveals a Hugh Jackman face
cut-out and stapled to his own face to hide
his scars from Vanessa.
And there's even a fourth wall meta joke with
Deadpool pointing out a fourth wall break
within another fourth wall, a nod to the time
when Deadpool has explained the fourth wall
to other comic characters in the comic books.
Other fourth wall breaks include Deadpool
saying "Cue The Music" and when he freezes
the action to explain why this is a different
kind of superhero movie.
And there is an absolute barrage of pop culture
references, for example Deadpool has an Adventure
Time watch and a Hello Kitty duffel bag, he
jokes about Honey Boo Boo reality TV star
Mama June, he argues about the merits of different
IKEA furniture with Blind Al, he has a Deadpool
toy on the shelf in his apartment as well
as a Star Wars lunchbox, and he pokes fun
at Batman and Robin, saying Robin loves Batman.
And speaking of Batman, when Wade wonders
if his mask is muffling his voice, it's a
little jab at Tom Hardy's Bane in The Dark
Knight Rises.
When fellow bar patron Buck comments that
he'd 'hit this' in reference to Vanessa, she
makes a Lord of the Rings reference when she
grabs his balls and tells him to 'say the
words, fat Gandalf'.
And Wade tells Vanessa to 'Hakuna his tatas',
making a Lion King reference to the song Hakuna
Matata.
Wade's promise that he'll return and boombox
Careless Whisper outside Vanessa's window
is a nod to director Cameron Crowe's first
movie Say Anything, where John Cusack plays
Peter Gabriel's In Your Eyes outside his ex-girlfriend's
window.
There's several other musical jokes in the
movie including nods to nu metal band Limp
Bizkit, the rock band Spin Doctors, and, of
course, more mentions of Wham!'s second album,
Make It Big, which featured Careless Whisper;
and Deadpool also wears a t-shirt from the
rock musical Rent.
Oh, and Negasonic Teenage Warhead's shaven
head leads Deadpool to tell her 'nothing compares
2 u' and to call her Sinead, after Irish singer
Sinead O'Connor who had a massive hit with
that song back in 1990, and he also calls
Warhead 'Ripley from Alien 3', after Sigourney
Weaver's iconic character in that movie.
There's also a great joke about the Taken
franchise and its star Liam Neeson's parenting
skills; and a shout-out to The Godfather when
Deadpool turns up at the X-Mansion and tells
Colossus that 'I've got an offer you can't
refuse'; and in the montage where Deadpool's
searching for Francis, the kill using a Zamboni
ice resurfacer is a nod to Austin Powers.
Weasel suggests Wade should start making his
own horror movies as his face looks like the
Nightmare On Elm Street character 'Freddie
Krueger fucked a topographical map of Utah'.
There's also a nod to the Marvel Comics' Blade
franchise when Weasel tells Ajax and Angel
Dust to enjoy their Blade 2 midnight screening,
which is interesting as Ryan Reynolds has
said it was his role as vampire hunter Hannibal
King in Blade: Trinity which brought him to
the attention of a Fox executive, who thought
that character and Deadpool had many similarities
and asked him to play the role.
The reference to Danny Boyle's movie 127 Hours
when Deadpool saws off his own hand was brilliant,
and just before he jumps on to the garbage
truck, he also references author Judy Blume's
1970 young adult novel, 'Are You There God?
It's Me, Margaret.'
Also when Deadpool introduces himself to taxi
driver Dopinder as "Pool, Dead" it feels like
a funny twist on James Bond's classic line
"Bond, James Bond", and he also tells Dopinder
that director Ron Howard's sci-fi movie Cocoon
about a bunch of old people made young again
by an alien 'life force' is 'pure pornography'.
When Deadpool and Blind Al argue about whether
looks are important or not, he asks her: 'what
do I keep telling you, Mrs Magoo?', a nod
to the near-sighted cartoon character Mr Magoo.
And when Blind Al says 'looks aren't everything',
Deadpool keeps the pop-culture and meta-references
flowing with his comments on footballer David
Beckham's high-pitched voice, and adds 'do
you think Ryan Reynolds got this far on his
superior acting method?'
The various toy or animated unicorns and rainbow
jokes are a reference to the popular memes
of Deadpool riding a unicorn or Pegasus.
The final scene where Wade says to Colossus
"I'm just a boy about to stand in front of
a girl and tell her, WTF am I going to tell
her?" is a parody of Notting Hill where Julia
Roberts says to Hugh Grant "I'm also just
a girl standing in front of a boy asking him
to love her".
There's a whole bunch of meta-moments in the
movie, for example, right at the start Deadpool
picks up a Haunted Segway Tours leaflet, looks
at it thoughtfully and then saves it in his
suit.
This could be a joke about the narrative structure
of the film and the way Deadpool plays around
segwaying between different times and places.
Throughout the movie, Deadpool pokes fun at
the superhero genre in general and shows how
self-aware he is, for example, he jokes about
superhero landings and how bad they are for
your knees; and when he thinks of the pros
and cons of being a superhero, he lists "lucrative
film deals, both origin stories and larger
ensemble team movies" as a positive.
Oh, and at the bar when Weasel tells Wade
the Recruiter guy wants to talk to him, he
adds 'it may further the plot'; and later
when Wade comes up with his alias Deadpool,
Weasel comments 'that sounds like a fucking
franchise'.
And the animated unicorn which shits money
during the closing credits as the producers'
names appear on the screen is a joke about
them doing very well for themselves out of
these superhero movies!
The post-credits scene where Deadpool appears
in his Ferris Bueller-style dressing gown
and asks "why are you all still here?"
is a meta-reference to the popularity of post-credits
scenes in comic book movies, especially Marvel
movies.
The look of the whole scene owes a lot to
director John Hughes' film Ferris Bueller's
Day Off, from the layout of the room and its
two doors to the pictures on the wall, and
the wallpaper.
And Reynolds even ends the post-credits with
chicka-chicka, from Yello's song 'Oh Yeah',
which also featured in the classic 80s comedy.
Ok, guys, what other easter eggs and references
did you spot in Deadpool?
What was your favourite moment in the movie?
I can't wait to read your comments below!
If you want to check out more of my Deadpool
videos, I've got links to my playlist here,
including 10 Things You Didn't Know About
Deadpool and my review of the movie.
And don't forget to subscribe and leave a
comment about your favourite easter egg on
this video for a chance to win some awesome
Deadpool merch!
For more details and ways to enter the comp,
check out the Gleam link in the video description
below!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!